hello everyone and welcome to an
extremely complicated game from round
four of defeated world cup 2021 it's
rados lavoitech versus magnus carlsen
and
like we said there are 33 two players
left in the video world cup
and this is the first game that we're
going to show from round four so let's
check it out uh like i said really
complicated one and you'll see that even
though it's a classical game that there
simply was not enough time to
uh to play out all the variants in this
game and we're just gonna show a few of
them
uh since it's uh it's very enjoyable but
it is extremely complicated so without
further ado
uh watashi with the white pieces opens
with d4
we have knight to f6 by magnus uh uh
c4 e6 g3 and now d5 so we have the
catalan opening on the board
bishop to g2 and bishop to e7 we have
knight to f3 and the both players castle
so castles castles you know there are a
couple of very very popular lines um
there are over a thousand uh games in
the database with
each of these ideas for example d
captures on c4 c6s and idea knight b to
d7
many many moves here but magnus chooses
one that hasn't been played all that
much maybe some 30 games in the database
he advances the pawn on the queen side
to a5 but like i said it's not a new
move
so queen to c2 with usher continues
developing we have c6
and knight b to d2 now and there is one
game where
knight the a6 was played but here we
have b6 by magnus and it is now already
as of move eight that we have a
completely new game
uh so let's see how eradicate continues
here we have e4
striking in the center if black allows
it why not bishop to b7
and now rook to d1 developing the rook
also the queen is still on d8 so
it definitely definitely makes sense we
have knights to a6
and now yeah the knight will have to
figure out how to get into the game
maybe via the b4 square but maybe
something like knight
c7 then the d5 if this pawn ever moves
but it uh it really all depends on what
white plays so here we have e5 attacking
the knight on f6
knight to d7 and now uh c captures on d5
magnus now plays knight to b4 attacking
the queen
first before uh recapturing on d5 queen
to b1
and now not knight captures but rather c
captures on d5 promoting this spawn to a
central pawn
and freeing up the c6 square for the
knight if needed if white plays a3 at
some
point so here uh the knight here not
really doing all that much blocking the
bishop so knight f1 this knight is being
shifted over to e3
bishop to a6 now with this pawn now on a
light square on d5 the bishop isn't
really doing all that much here so we
might as well
uh improve the the activity of this
bishop and at some point uh if
the the bishop really will be useless
and it might be all of your pawns here
on light squares
you might even decide to trade it with
something like bishop to e2 maybe
captures on f3
yeah and so on so knights to e3 and now
rook to c8 by magnus putting the rook on
the only open file on the board we have
a3 chasing away the knight
knight to c6 and now we have b3
and here uh the position is very very
complicated there are so many ways you
can continue with black here
uh so many options and magnus took over
35 minutes i think for his next move
because there's a lot to consider
uh like we said bishop to e2 is always
an idea
for example if you go something like
this attack the rook and the knight
let's say rook d2 captures captures and
then you want to
attack white's um advanced center
because white's uh
center is really really strong so of
course we will undermine it at some
point with f6
but before doing this magnus first place
b5 and b5
uh asks white what is your plan what are
you doing here i can always play this
idea
i'm going to continue pushing my pawns
on the queen side
what are you going to do so here uh
radhik plays h4
uh grabs more space on the king side
also makes some room for the king if
needed
and now b4 and now he has to decide
whether he wants to play captures but
then he allows
captures by uh uh choices this can
capture this can capture this can
capture probably knight captures
uh this pawn is nicely defended by the
queen and the knight is now beautiful
and b4 there's no a pawn or c
pawn to dislodge it from there so radik
decides to keep the queen side close
with a4
and now magnus goes for this bishop to
e2 idea we have rook to d2
bishop captures bishop captures and now
that the remover uh
not remover defender of the center has
been removed we have f6 now
uh challenging white's very strong
center so by playing f6
black also left something behind now the
e6 pawn is very very weak so uh radical
just
attacks it and there's no way to defend
the e6 pawn other than to advance the
pawn all the way to f5
so this way white keeps the center
closed and he doesn't have to worry
about
those knights coming alive anytime soon
so here
f5 by magnus the only way to defend the
e6 pawn and now
if you move the knight if you move the
bishop then black pretty much just gets
uh
what what black ones you have f4 you
have bishop captures on h4 there are so
many ideas here
so uh radic just goes and knight
captures on f5 and it makes sense to
destroy
uh black center even further and then
your own center will become
much much stronger plus also after e
captures and bishop captures
you grab two pawns for a piece also
you're attacking h7 so you can't really
expect um uh you know to have a bad game
here and of course g6 just runs into
bishop characters and either on g6 or an
e6 and it's going to be
a pretty bad game if white wants white
white can you even
grab an instant draw here for example
magnus doesn't want to allow this
so after this bishop captures on a on f5
we have bishop
captures on h4 and now what do you play
here
it's a really really uh tricky tricky
position now you could
decide to capture the bishop right away
it this was played in the game
but also you can do pretty much anything
else you can capture on h7 we will show
what happens uh if bishop captures an h7
and i don't think there's enough time
even in the classical game to calculate
bishop captures on h7 because it's
just too much for example king to h8 and
now
queen to g6 and uh check this out now
queen to g5 and look at this setup here
uh i don't think
we've ever seen this this is so so uh
incredible uh that what do you even do
here well here
white will play rook to d1 and attack
the black queen
and now magnus of course uh will not
move the queen but
will play knight captures on e5 and
attack the white queen again
and now after the captures now we're
gonna capture with the queen and now
we're attacking the rook on a1 so bishop
to e3 so now the rooks are connected
but now magnus has for example bishop
captures on g3 and now you have to
capture with the queen otherwise if this
captures then you capture this with the
trick
so sorry about that uh so queen would
have to capture end for example queen
captures f captures and now we're gonna
capture here on h7
uh rook will capture on d5 the material
is completely equal let's say rook to f3
as the white is attacking the a5 pawn
and we get this position where
who knows what is happening and uh well
even if you're able to get all all the
way to here in your head
and then you know still have to assess
this position it's not going to be
easy and you're going to burn a lot of
time and the players are already down
a lot uh on time so after carlson's
bishop captures an h4
uh bishop captures an h7 was not played
an an interesting idea is just rook to
d1 maybe just uh you know
allowing the bishop to reclaim this
square so maybe the queen can't come to
g5 but also requires too much time
and after considering the position for a
while
g captures on h4 was played and now the
situation on the clock is some 37
minutes for
for erratic and 15 minutes for magnus so
that's not really a lot of time
and magnus has to figure out how to how
to continue in this position now there
are a lot of ways to continue
this is even the position from the
thumbnail now that i've made the dh4
square red now you realized it
so feel free to pause the video here and
you know let's see what you would play
here while i give you a couple of
seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on playing what
magnus played
queen captures an h4 but there seems to
be an even greater line and that is
knight c
captures on e5 and this is uh again i i
would say impossible to calculate
someone like tal would maybe go into
this without even calculating but
you know the times have changed a lot uh
and
now another thing is after the captures
you can play knight captures and you
don't even care about the rook and
the problem is uh if bishop captures on
c8 you're going to play queen
captures on c8 and now look at the
position uh
the white king is completely open the
rook now has
control of the file the queen has access
to the king side the knight is a monster
here prepared to jump to f3
and there's no no way for white to
continue the game uh because all of
these squares look at this g6 covered by
the knight discovered by the rook
discovered by the pawn discovered by the
knight
and this uh so well somewhat controlled
by by the queen and there's no square
for the white queen if you try something
like
queen to c2 uh you don't really care
just knight f3
and the white is getting checkmated king
to f1 we're going to deliver
queen to a h3 check king e2 now comes
knight to g1 with
check again the king is cut off from the
third rank you have to go back into e1
now rookie 8 check king d1 and let's say
queen to f1 will be checkmate so
really uh just amazing stuff uh and even
if you don't play this after let's say
this
um queen comes to see it you know you
don't play something like this what else
are you going to play there is no way to
activate your pieces for example rook to
a2 uh we just continue knight f3 check
and it's the same idea king f1 rook e8
cuts off the king from the e file
queen to h3 will quickly decide things
there's no no defending this
uh so really uh a crazy crazy line uh
but like i said after g
captures on h4 uh magnus was already
very much down on the clock he played
queen captures on h4
and now the position is still uh far
from a draw
uh white has a a variety of options that
white can play uh he played bishop to e6
check now if you're wondering
what's what's with the knight here why
not just capture the knight
well then we uh play this knight capture
sunday for move and
this knight simply gets into the attack
way way too quickly there's
no no real way to defend this and it's
just uh
it's just uh completely completely lost
uh for
uh for white even if you play something
like rook captures here then of course
you're no longer defending the f2 pawn
you're getting checkmated so
it's uh crazy crazy position so of
course the knight cannot be captured
bishop to e6 check was played king to h8
and now queen to d3 eradic finally gets
his queen back into the game
and now magnus continues happily giving
up material knight
d captures on e5 again offering the rook
offering the knight
everything is hanging here this is one
very very enjoyable game
but i would also like to mention because
this is a classical game and the players
are very low on time
there was the um the well
seemingly crazy queen to e7
it's a really really cool move that now
uh asks what do you do with the bishop
and the problem is if bishop captures on
d5 now
now we play knight captures on c5 and
after d captures knight captures now the
position is uh
a bit different because uh well uh
it's just a much much uh a better
position for black
with the bishop on d5 now for example
rook to e2 we try
pinning this knight but now black has
rook captures and c1 with
check rook captures and queen to g5 with
check
connecting with the rook here and after
let's say queen to g3
you can't really leave your queen on d3
otherwise you're going to lose it so
queen g3
queen captures with checking to h2 now
let's say knight g6 and the position
is uh well what it is black is up upon
but not just that white the white king
is completely wide open his
uh you know defenses are busted and it
would be a much better position for
black so
even moves like this are in the position
but okay knight d
captures and if i was played we have d
characters knight captures now with an
attack on the queen but now queen
captures on d5 and this is
uh opposed to queen being on d3 and the
bishop and d5 a little better for white
so knight to f3 with check connecting
with the rook here
but now uh you can't really move if you
if you move the king and it doesn't
really matter where you move the king
let's take the g2
just queen to h2 check king to f1 queen
g1 check and now after king to e2
there's queen the e1
check and now king d3 rook to c3 will be
checkmate so
extremely uh ugly for for white so
instead after knight to f3 check radik
did
the only thing he could and that is
queen captures an
f3 so very very very nicely done queen
captures an f3
he gives up the queen and uh well what
do you play now of course you have to
capture it with rook captures on f3
now bishop captures on c8 and not well
there's the problem of the back rank
just
uh not at the moment the queen is
guarding the d8 square but it is uh
uh it is very tough to you know handle
this
for black because you are you do have a
queen but white has a bishop pair and if
the rooks you know somehow get into the
game could be could be very ugly and
here magnus just goes back rook to f2
because he's already down to five
minutes
and radik has some uh 13 minutes on the
clock but if you weren't in a
in a rush to do this maybe h6 maybe rook
captures on b3 all of this is in the
position but it doesn't matter
rook f8 comes with tempo the bishop is
under attack
so bishop to b7 now both players are
below five minutes
radik also spent some time on this
bishop to b7 move
and now queen to f6 attacking the rook
uh and uh just asking what do you do
and this is a great move because it
gives white uh a lot of
options on on how to go wrong for
example if rook to b1 just queen g6
check picks up the rook
uh there's also that and if you don't
play rook to b1
uh you might also consider something
like a rook eight to a two to get the
rook into the game this way
but now we play queen e7 we attack the
bishop and the weed or
white will either lose this bishop or
queen to e1 check you're going to lose
this bishop so
of course you don't want to lose any of
your bishops so after queen to f6 we
have rook d to a2 the ugliest looking
move possible but it is what is needed
to survive the position
so queen to f7 by magnus now with an
attack on the bishop and the b3 pawn
uh now magnus saying i i i didn't
have to capture the b3 pawn right away
i'm going to capture it now
so bishop back to g2 queen captures on
b3
grabbing that pawn now creating the past
b pawn uh
bishop to e3 finally the the kind of
completing development and now
rook to d8 and as magnus played this he
was already extremely low on the clock
going for the one minute mark uh and uh
radic was also losing a lot of time but
uh
interesting as it is it was uh in this
position that the players agreed to a
draw
so uh i did i don't know who who uh who
offered the draw i imagine it was magnus
uh as uh he's the one that played the
move so i imagine he played the move and
then offered the draw and the radik was
spending some time to decide or maybe he
was it was radical but i i if i had to
guess i
i would guess it was magnus it looks
like there's so much to play for but uh
all the time in the world would not be
enough because there are
so many things you have to calculate
here and both players uh well
are still very much low on time and they
still have to make five more moves uh to
reach time to
control both of them and so i guess they
agree that the the fair result here is a
draw so magnus will try uh tomorrow with
the white piece and the radical of
course do his best
to hold him off with the black pieces
but to give you an example
i let the engine crunch the the position
a little bit here
at the some depth of 35 you know it
would take
too much time as it's a complicated
position uh but for example
white could continue with something like
rook to e2 it's a it's a kind of a force
line because uh
rook to d1 check is the idea that magnus
had in
mind when he played rook to d8 uh but
now we're still going to play this rook
to d1
check capture capture now check
connecting with the rook so now bishop
to f1
and here although it seems like black
now gets to push his past b
pawn not really because you have bishop
to f4 magnus
has a really weak back rank and this
thread of checkmate uh
uh makes black waste the move so here h5
wasting a move and now bishop to e5 and
now all
things are already looking quite quite
good for white
because well you have a very nice bishop
here you're guarding the b2 square twice
there's no way to advance the past pawn
and at some point you're gonna get the
rook into the game you're gonna put the
king on g to maybe get the bishop into
the game and you know
could be could be very unpleasant if
those bishops and
the rook become fully operational so
after rook 28
players agreed to a draw and like i said
this amazing amazing game was played and
there simply was not enough time to
calculate all that was happening here
but such is the case when uh when you're
playing classical chess and you have
these uh awesome
engine lines fully prepared so you know
when uh you you have to start crunching
numbers in your head it just
goes out of hand and you waste a lot of
time
and then you know this is the the result
so really an awesome complicating uh
complicated game
i hope you guys enjoyed that we're going
to check some of the other games so do
use hashtag suggestion uh so i you know
spot them there are 32 uh more uh
players left so
there are there's plenty to to enjoy uh
so yeah once again hope you guys enjoyed
it
i would like to thank steven wentworth
to matthew parker tom darillo richard
campbell and robert walker for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the video
world cup
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank you i will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day